يترقب محمد الانتخابات التركيه وسط مخاوف
يعيشها كباقي اللاجئين من انعكاسات قد
تؤثر على لجوئهم ووجودهم في تركيا وذلك مع
تلويح الاحزاب التركيه بملف اللاجئين في
حملاتهم الانتخابيه من وقت الحالي في حاله
ترقب وغير مسبوقه بصراحه نتيجه الانتخابات
التركيه تعرف نحن صرنا ورقه ضغط لجميع
الاحزاب التركيه سواء بسيطات الاحزاب
المعارضه او سيطره حزب العداله والتنميه
ففي هنا في عندك عوده طبيعيه وعوده
اجباريه وحاليا عايشين حول الترقب نحن
وجميع السوريين في خوف في خوف طبيعي الناس
خايفه ترجع لسوريا
الخلاف التركي التركي حول التعامل مع ملف
اللاجئين السوريين ليس وليد اليوم فقد
ازدادت حملات التحريض على السوريين في
الفتره الماضيه من قبل شخصيات واحزاب
مختلفه لم يفصل الجدار الحدودي مع تركيا
مخاوف السوريين من انعكاسات الانتخابات
التركيه عليهم
فاللاجئون في تركيا والنازحون في الشمال
السوري يحبسون انفاسهم لمعرفه ماء سيتغير
حالهم بعد الانتخابات
يرى السوريون في الشمال السوري ان نتائج
الانتخابات التركيه لا بد ان تنعكس على
الملف السوري بشكل عام وليس على وجود
اللاجئين في تركيا فحسب كعلاء الذي يترقب
نتائج الانتخابات وما ستحمله من انعكاسات
على الشمال السوري وعلى اخيه وعائلته
اللاجئين في تركيا نتمنى نتمنى انه انه
انه مالات الانتخابات التركيه بتكون
ايجابيه وتصب في خانه مصلحه السوري سواء
انا متواجد في تركيا او نتواجد في الداخل
السوري ونتمنى من نفس الوقت انه نتائج هاي
الانتخابات تثمر عند عند فتح افق جديد في
الملف السوري كونه القصاصه وكونه في حاله
انسداد وانغلاق على مستوى السياسي وغيره
وغيره حاله التدافع السياسي بين الاحزاب
التركيه وطريقه تعاملها مع الملف السوري
دفعت السوريين في الشمال السوري واللاجئين
في تركيا للميول الى حزب العداله والتنميه
والرئيسيه رجب طيب اردوغان محمد الاشقر
العربيه الحدود السوريه التركيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات